speaking of fizzling app our good friend
Joe Biden is still running for president
we'll get a little bit more into the
presidential election later but let's
not forget this man is still running and
he is losing more and more of his
consciousness every single day they are
trying to go back and gin up this
coronavirus idea well Joe Biden has a
scary number for you he is under the
impression that coronavirus has hit 120
million people already worldwide I just
got off the phone this morning with dr.
Vivek Murthy and he and and others who
he was a former Surgeon General and a
number of experts who work I have a
meeting hour and a half telephone
conference with them zoom conference
once a week I mean four times a week and
that's why we have a major multi-billion
dollar investment in mental health
well people drastically underestimated
is the impact on the mental health of
people who now everything is complicated
not only is the health care piece but
people don't have a job people don't
have anywhere to go they don't know what
they're going to do and a lot of people
you have unnecessarily now we have over
120 million dead from covent hundred I
mean 120 million dead you know it's
funny I actually have to correct myself
the first time I heard that clip I
thought he was saying over 120 million
cases worldwide which obviously is not
true no what he said it's even crazier
he's saying there's 120 million dead and
it seems he's implying in America which
is a country of 330 million people
that's a lot huh that's actually though
the number is not anywhere close to that
it's multiple orders of magnitude lower
than that watching or listening to Joe
Biden these days you have to think the
man is not up to the job and yet the
poll numbers show he's actually in a
pretty good position or the polls lying
possibly but does president Trump think
he's gonna sail to re-election I think
probably not
[Music]
[Music]